bonjour c'est monsieur dream monsieur
dream points comme le blog est ouvert
aujourd'hui je vais vous parler d'un
truc mais je sais je sais plus de quoi
jouer ou en tout cas aujourd'hui je vais
vous parler un petit peu deux mc
donald's et je dis pas ça parce que j'y
ai mangé hier ou avant-hier
ou les deux déjà je pense que ça ne doit
arriver qu'à moins mais quand je vais
dans la queue au mcdo je vais toujours
dans la queue qui va le moins vite c'est
comme ça j'y peux rien c'est peut être
mon super pouvoir ça ne sert à rien que
je change de que je tomberai toujours
sur une queue avec des gens qui veulent
prendre un congé pour 160 des gens qui
c'est de payer en francs des gens qui
visitent d'ailleurs vous l'aurez
remarqué il ya deux types de gens qui
vont au mcdo 1 d'abord et les gens qui
savent ce qu'ils veulent je vais prendre
un maxi best of de luxe et steve
frissonner carmel et puis il ya ceux qui
ont l'impression d'avoir le destin de la
planète entre leurs marges sont leur
venue alors je vais prendre une boîte de
de nos repas à maxime et un maxi best of
un maxi best of happy meal avec non non
non royal cheese sans fromage
après avoir attendu dans la queue la
plus longue du monde ça c'est super
pouvoirs je choisis mon menu donc ça je
fais plutôt partie des gens qui savent
ce qu'ils veulent
par contre je doute d'une chose parce
que quand je vois le big mac qu'il ya
sur la fiche au dessus des caisses et
celui qui est sur mon plateau
je ne sais pas ce qu'il s'est passé mais
apparemment il s'est passé quelque chose
de grave
certes c'est toujours un big mac mais
probablement un cousin très éloigné de
celui sur l'afficheur symétrique la
salade et soul hamburger le dedans on
dirait un burger en petite et la botte
et au tri dans les frites c'est quoi
cette histoire quand tu prends des
frites
il ya toujours une ou deux potes et aux
dedans tu sais pas pourquoi comme si les
potatoes ont essayé de s'échapper en
passant par le bac à frites et pas des
roses ont franchi le bac afrique et puis
on est libre le truc que j'adore mcdo
c'est la fameuse légende urbaine il ya
toujours un bot à toi qui la raconte
quand on sait pas quoi dire bye-bye que
mcdo mais de lentilles vomitif dans son
orgueil paquet aussi des pâtes de
serpents mois s'était caché je sais pas
d'où ça vient cette histoire d'anti vous
mettiez vase on le regarde on m'aurait
dit qu'ils ajoutent des arômes pour que
ce soit meilleur d'accord je comprends
les anti vomitif enfin le type qui a
lancé cette rumeur c'est le pire lanceur
de rumeur du monde que et enfin le
mystère absolu les gens qui prennent une
demi-tonne de serviettes
j'ai vérifié à une à deux serviettes
suffit largement prendre pas alors
pourquoi comme si les gens isolés leur
maison avec les serviettes re année mais
franchement pourquoi à quoi ça sert mais
je ne sais pas à partir chez le cul
après ouais tu tu économises le papier
toilette ouais c'est sûr bon moi c'est
décidé j'arrête le mcdo c'est fini bikey
à du plutonium dans les frites me ferais
bien un petit quizz ce soir quand même
mais si driss et des restes de faire
drôle mais bon ça je sais pas